très loin c'est la première fois des
ouvriers en cela c'est à dire que deux
faits ici tout ce que pour l'ensemble
des plus grands initiation a décidé de
maigrir
on est loin ceux qui sont vraiment
bonnes donc je veux tu peux t'en moques
politiquement exactement savoir ce que
maintenant nous allons faire est
nouvelle ils se sentent menacés par les
étudiants d'extrême droite shicoff
cherchait à rentrer à la sorbonne et
charles ray contre vieux matériel
complet anti fasciste
la police entre dans la cour de la samba
les régimes fascistes les réactionnaires
le salon s'est jamais le jour
ramasser
en fait qu'est ce que je fous
mais rien n'a rien fait ça plus le monde
mais il a mal à la veillée se feront les
arènes lorraine